so hi welcome in European far away an
Austrian MEP greets a British scientist
in real life the two are not likely to
meet but the European Parliament is
making it happen under a scheme called
science meets Parliament's the best idea
is to meet with scientists out of
different area to understand what is the
work what they are doing how can people
get benefit out of their knowledge and
it is a very good idea to know how the
the legislature work in the EU climate
change biotechnology wireless networks
these are only some of the issues where
scientific expertise plays a major role
under the scheme em eps are paired with
scientists in their fields of interest
any piece can then make informed
decisions about complicated questions
while for scientists it's a way to get
involved in EU decision making on a more
personal level the scheme also enables m
eps and scientists to get an insight
into each other's work mep Ava Kelly has
chosen to meet with a professor in
bioengineering so for me it's important
because it's going to change my point of
view on the new materials the new ways
of designing these medical devices also
and how legislation makes it difficult
for them or how it could make it easier
for them in the end everyone will go
home with a better understanding of what
the other does